joining us now is someone who until a
few days ago was running to be
conservative leader himself the brexit
Minister James cleverly and thanks being
with us hi happy to well you've decided
to pull out the race yeah who you going
back well I've given it a lot of thought
I've spoken to my association I've
spoken to people in my constituency and
I've decided that I'm going to support
Boris Johnson as the leader of the party
I've worked with him in London I've
stood shoulder-to-shoulder with him on
to election campaigns both in 2008 and
in 2012 I've seen him reach out to
audiences and voters that the
Conservative Party would not normally
expect to be on side and I know he can
run a successful executive operation
because I was part of the team that did
that when we were in London for eight
years so that's why I'm gonna be
supporting him for leader when you were
running you were talking about the
importance of leader who was tested who
the paste is why is it you thing here
not him I think he needs to get out and
do a bit more media well the the first
hurdle you have to get over is getting
the supporter members of parliament and
I spend a lot of time in TV studios
talking to the wider electorate and
maybe in hindsight I should have spent
more time talking to other MPs so you've
got to get over the hurdles as they
appear in the first job you've got to do
is win over MPs I know he's had a whole
load of meetings he's had a number of
hostels last week they're gonna be more
hustings next week and he's been having
face-to-face meetings so I'm I'm the one
that's pulled out I'm not sure it's
relevant for me to criticize someone
else's strategy for every job no so I
spoken to all the candidates and none of
those conversations did I asked for or
indeed was offered a job the really
important thing is to make sure that we
deliver brexit the things I said when I
was running deliver brexit and then very
quickly set about talking to the country
about the issues that really matter
which is about you know schools and it's
about how we look after our elderly
members of our society as a party how we
reach out not just to our traditional
voter base but beyond that as well and
that's the kind of thing that I think is
important and I've spoken with Boris and
he's very much I think looking at a
similar kind of agenda to to the one
that I was trying to put forward okay
now the debate about drugs has been
dominat
the papers over the last few days I just
wanna read something that you said in a
debate recently we have to educate the
people who think that drug use that
occasional line of code coats on middle
class party is a victimless crime it's
not there is an absolute causal
relationship between that so-called
victimless crime at some party or some
club and the kid that lies bleeding out
in a stairwell of a block of flats in
South London mm-hmm is that your view
someone who's my I mean I said it on the
floor of the House of Commons and it
yeah it is my it is my view and I think
that we do have to recognize the
implications of our actions all of us
and yeah I mean I stand by what I said I
mean you've said that you have done
marijuana though mm-hmm oh yeah and I
said no and I said you know and I said
at the time and I did that interview it
was a foolish thing and I regret it and
I certainly don't advise it or I've said
not blase about it and I do feel very
strongly that that you know when you
when you do foolish things in your youth
as you mature you need to think about
those things you need to reflect upon
those things and have the courage to be
honest about what's what what you've
done or what's happened and also what
you intend to do to change that
circumstance okay just finally and we
interviewed you I just want to play
everywhere something you said my turn to
go up quickly quick fire round
oh just well we've got you has to be
down there you'd be better Prime
Minister you're barmy no hesitation
that's all what why do you think did you
think that you make it better Prime
Minister the problem I had is not so
much what I thought is what other MPs
thought and they didn't agree with me
so do you still think you'd be a better
PM than Boris Johnson well look you took
part of the job of being a PM is winning
over the support of my start whilst I
did okay I didn't do well enough to have
a credible chance of winning and as I
said to you in that interview I think
you know I was in it to win it and when
it became clear that I wasn't really on
the cards if you can't win there's no
point in running so that's why I would
true okay James Clary thank you for
being inclusive